Nowadays,
it's incredibly hard to stay focused.
There's so many distractions that are
around us at any given moment.
Um,
your pocket vibrates at any given
moment.
A cause bigger,
getting 10 new emails and on social
media there's all these new
notifications and the phone is ringing
and your kids need help and your
colleagues are coming up because you are
working in an open office plan and
they're asking you to chime in on some
memo.
Maintaining focus nowadays is harder
than ever before,
but in some ways it's way more critical
to,
one of the things that we know about the
most productive people and the most
productive companies is that they create
ways to enhance their focus.
They,
they manage their mind in such a way
that they're able to focus on what's
important and ignore distractions much
better.
And the way that they do this is by
what's known as building mental models,
essentially telling themselves stories
about what they expect to see,
engaging in this kind of inner dialogue
about what they think should be
happening that allows their brain almost
subconsciously to figure out what to pay
attention to and what to ignore.
One of my favorite examples of this is a
big study that was done of nurses in
Nicu as some researchers from a group
named client associates went into some
hospitals because they wanted to figure
out why some nurses were so good at
paying attention to the right things,
whereas others got distracted by all the
noise and bustle around them.
And what they found is that the best
nurses in Nicu is,
which is the neonatal intensive care
unit who are handling these babies.
The nurses who are almost had a sixth
sense or an esp about figuring out which
babies were sick and were getting
sicker.
We're the ones who were constantly
telling themselves stories about what
they expected to see as they were
walking around the hospital.
So one of my favorite interviews from
this study was with a nurse named
Darlene.
Darlene said that what she would do is
that she always was keeping a picture in
her brain of what she thought that the
perfect baby should look like.
And so she would walk through the unit
and she would notice when babies didn't
kind of match that picture in her brain.
Right.
And they would match.
They would mismatch that picture and
kind of odd ways.
Like she might be walking past a crib
and she might expect a baby to be crying
because babies cry all the time.
And so if a baby was being uniquely
silent,
she would go over and she would try and
figure out what's going on.
Like why is this baby being so quiet now
to all the other nurses are quiet baby
seems like a good thing.
It seems like that baby is happy and it
doesn't need any attention.
But to Darlene because she has this
picture in her head of what the perfect
baby should look like when she sees a
quiet baby,
she thinks that doesn't match the
picture in my head.
I need to go pay attention.
And so she'd walk over and she'd see all
these things that are all small issues
on their own,
right.
The maybe the baby's blood was taken
from its heel and instead of a dot of
blood on the bandaid,
if there's a little bit of a bigger
splotch,
um,
maybe the,
the baby's temperature is a little bit
elevated,
but nothing that like is out of place.
Nothing that's worrisome.
But for Darlene and nurses like this who
keep this picture in their head,
this mental model of what should be
occurring,
all of those things don't jive with the
story inside their head.
And so as a result,
their attention is grabbed by it and
they start saying to themselves,
why?
Why is this baby bleeding a little bit
more than I expected?
Why is its temperature off just a few
degrees?
And in this case,
they discovered that the baby was
incredibly sick.
Now there was not a lot of evidence that
it was second.
In fact,
if they had waited half an hour,
45 minutes more,
the baby actually probably would have
passed away.
But because Darlene noticed all of these
things because the baby that she was
seeing in real life didn't match the
picture in her head.
She acted immediately.
They started,
they started the child on antibiotics.
The sepsis infection in its system was,
was stamped out,
but the only reason that Darlene was
able to notice these warning signs,
the only reason she sort of had this esp
or sixth sense for something going wrong
was because she had a strong mental
model.
She had a picture in her head that she
was comparing reality too.
Now,
not all of us work in Nicu is right.
We don't work in hospitals.
We're not dealing with life or death
issues,
but think for a minute about what it's
like when you walk into a meeting and
your boss asks you an unexpected
question or you're,
you're,
I'm sitting there and you're,
you're juggling the kids and dinner and
suddenly your phone vibrates and it's
this email that's,
that causes the spike of panic.
Our instinct at a moment like that is to
react immediately to type something that
we end up regretting later on or to
answer our boss and blurt something out
and we think to ourselves afterwards,
God,
I could've put that so much more
eloquently.
Why are some people so much better at
maintaining their focus and not reacting
and not getting distracted by all these
things?
It's because ahead of time they've
envisioned what they expect to it to see
they've envisioned what they expect to
occur.
So on the subway,
when they're riding to work,
they think about what is this day going
to be like?
I know that I'm going to this meeting.
What do I expect to occur at that
meeting?
And so when they walk in and their boss
asked them some unexpected question,
they their brain,
almost subconsciously,
he says,
I didn't expect that question to occur.
This isn't matching the picture in my
brain of what I anticipated.
So I need to put that question off.
I need to to say,
can we take that offline and I'll answer
that later.
Or they have a picture in their brain of
what it's going to be like to to deal
with the kids and to make dinner.
There's some type of expectation and so
as a result,
when their pocket buzzes and an email
comes in,
they can say,
I can't handle this right now.
I need to give myself five minutes and
I'll deal with this later.
I use this all the time.
They used to be that when I would ride
the subway into work,
I would spend that time reading the
paper or I would try and get caught up
on,
you know,
memos or or something else.
What I do now is I put everything away
and I spend that 30 minutes just trying
to envision what is this day going to be
like because I know that the more that I
have thought through what's about to
occur,
the more that I have a strong vision in
my mind of what I should expect and
anticipates,
the more my subconscious is going to be
able to decide this is what you should
focus on.
This is what you can safely ignore.
I'm trying to train my brain by just
doing a couple of minutes of thinking
through what's about to occur to make
better decisions about where my focus
should actually be.
Go.